on MSNBC a network tuesdaya guests
mocked fox news for devoting time to the
murder of Molly Tibbets I'm sure we'll
hear what he has to say about this at
his his rally the Fox News is talking
about you know a girl in Iowa and not
this right right a girl in Iowa she's
right and a girl in Iowa murdered pales
and importance when compared to tax
evasion because if you talk about Molly
you can't talk about the things that the
media thinks is important to the press
your sorrow over a young woman's death
is got to be political and that hush
money among adults is more harmful to
society than a brutal killing the media
is obsessed with mana fort and cohan
victimless gotcha
crimes but for most Americans we know a
true victim when we see her it ain't the
IRS or stormy and so we're smeared for
thinking murder matters more than a bad
Ted and for T so maybe we need to help
the media find equivalencies let me ask
you dear media how many Molly's is a
Mike Cohen worth the answer as many as
it takes to undo an election and the
facts be damned on Sunday this story
took off on Twitter ice had nabbed a guy
on the way to the hospital with his
pregnant wife it was perfect media
fodder until we later found out the dad
was a murder suspect so mysteriously
that story went away or how about the
Nazi death camp guard living in Queens
Obama's White House knew about him but
ignored it even as the Nazis Jewish
neighbors called him out then we had an
election and Trump using ice deported
him so without ice we'd have at least
one Nazi on the loose if this is the
first time you've heard of these stories
I get it these days you stick to the
story you want to tell which is why to
some Molly Tibbets is just some girl in
Iowa to be fair I want to run this
apology from the Fordham professor
Christine Greer who said apologized on
Twitter it's a non apology but let's run
it anyway
she says yesterday I said something
flippant that was unintended Molly
Tibbets was a problem
young woman who lost her life problem my
hope is that her family will find peace
of justice and that her murder is not
used to justify a discriminatory
immigration policy Dana from a public
relations perspective she probably could
have stopped that apology when it
mattered yes it's one of my things I
can't stand about things like backhanded
apologies or like what if somebody says
I've never agreed with her in my entire
life but she had a good point there like
I can they don't want to Soleil
themselves with that yet
whenever you see a but coming it's not
an apology stop yes just put a period
yeah exactly or an and and then say
something more kind the abolish ice
bumper-sticker leaves no room for
complexity or nuance and so you have a
situation where Democrats are having to
answer questions like are you for
abolishing ice are you for abolished ice
and most of them like no yeah I'm not
for abolishing ice but because there are
some left-wing folks out there that
really want to try to get a rise out of
people and probably believe that we
should abolish ice they have backed a
lot of Democrats into the corner on this
mmm Pam welcome to the show could be CNN
and MSNBC they didn't take the
arraignment for the suspect because they
believe that's not news I guess he has a
private attorney I was wondering who was
paying for that but also how did he get
through I keep I've read different
stories did he did they do eve Arif I on
him did he have a fake ID yeah it's
saying that and the farm owner says that
he went through a verify he turned over
completely cooperated to turn over all
the documents and then dssh and now I
they're looking at it to see what
happened with verify but this guy's been
in the country forever and he murdered a
beautiful young girl from being in a
courtroom my entire career that's who
everybody in this country should be
focusing on that victim its parents her
family can you imagine what they're
going through
yeah no it's it's unimaginable you know
and we talk about families being
separated
that's that separation I want to run
wand for you some tape from Elizabeth
Warren she was talking about this case
lamenting the crime but then inserting
above
I'm so sorry for the family here and I
know this is hard not only for the
family but for the people in her
community the people throughout Iowa but
one of the things we have to remember is
we need an immigration system that is
effective that focuses on where real
problems are so it one I guess this
isn't a real problem that this young
woman was murdered
no that's I mean the way you set it up
is so prejudicial to our audience here I
mean the clear fact of what happened is
just horrible to this young woman but
it's also amazed me the Kate Steinle
case where her brother Brad came forward
and said that he thought Trump was
sensationalizing the death of a
beautiful young woman why would her
brother why would Kate Stanley's
brothers say that because what you see
is that people use this for their own
purpose and Trump's case he's using us
to distract and to deceive people in
terms of the big news of the day which
is about the Michael Cohen plea deal
about Paul Manafort being convicted I
mean at this point you have the
president's personal lawyer his campaign
chairman his national security adviser
all convicted felons and you know
instead we want to talk about a murder
well they lots of murders in America
there's a lower rate of violent crime
among we got the illegal immigrants and
immigrants and there is among
native-born American and if that's what
there's some people who say let's not
talk about Trump because it's bad news
like let's talk about this
the point is essential deed like there
may be more people that are killed
texting while driving so let's not pay
attention to drunk driving we can
actually tackle both talked about the
news of the day which we did talking
about the Kohen of mana for cases in the
B Block
now we're leading the show with this
story so it seems like you're the one
that's trying to snow my story what
we're leading with a story about one
woman's death and no
Asian case yes the presidency of the
United States jesse is imperiled by
these decisions according to you but you
know who is really imperiled Molly now
let me just say something what happened
here was horrible and my heart goes out
to the family there's two levels of the
story I think one how many dead people
are we going to tolerate in this country
without solving the immigration problem
we have to have stricter borders we
can't have sanctuary and we have to do
something where you have to be able to
verify the people that are in here now
on the other hand the media does not
report these stories honestly and if you
look at this one and the other ones that
you mentioned up there there
misinforming the audience they're not
informing I looked at that story about
the arrest about the guy driving his
wife and you had to read six paragraphs
down to find out that he was wanted for
a homicide beef now that would seem like
something that would lead and actually
be in the headline but they don't they
don't inform their viewers and they're
doing it the same thing now that it's
found out that this person is allegedly
here illegally this has now dropped off
the top row of a lot of cable news
networks and a lot of newspapers and
it's a shame because the American people
need to understand the facts about these
things so they can elect politicians who
can then solve problems well let me just
say I don't think there's any
correlation between illegal immigration
and violent crime in our country but you
make that connection I don't think it's
fair to me you know what's interesting
is if there is a mass murder yesterday
all you guys would be saying you know
this is not the time to talk about gun
control let's not do that that's what
the right says so here I said today one
and you have one woman who was sadly
tragically killed in Iowa and you guys
want to start walking about everybody
happens in this country is that there's
tragic events and then politicians try
to lead and try to have solutions just
like it was a school shooting Democrats
want to do gun control or if there's a
hurricane Democrats want to talk about
climate change
I don't blame either side for doing it
that's what politicians are you know in
fact you sit here and say this is not
the time to talk about gun control in
the aftermath of a mass murder but now
not every matter I think
we have a broken fixing fix we have to
we have a broken system that needs
fixing a fixham as I like to call yeah a
fix him it needs to be fixed now they're
they I guess they claimed that they
thought they were wrong
he didn't get a verified that's the
that's what I'm learning it was a
different type of system it's yeah
that's that you verify one thing about
there's a Lamar Smith has a legislation
in front of Congress right now his
e-verify system would add that you would
be notified if your social security
number was put through the system that
you could say wait hold on like I'm
actually here my social security number
is being used and then verify should be
mandatory and you know as a prosecutor
when you're in the courtroom every day
for years dealing with victims you look
at the only way you can cope is looking
out at one victim at a time and how can
we prevent more young girls boys from
being murdered and that's why this is an
important dialogue